qu'olivier py ton avocat français au
barreau de washington observateurs de la
vie politique américaine
bonsoir olivier python merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur la défense alors
donald trump a qui se dit prêt tout d'un
coup a rencontré nicolás maduro
concrètement ça veut dire quoi c'est un
renversement stratégie on peut
l'interpréter comme ça en fait ce qui
est intéressant je trouve d'abord c'est
que c'est nicolas maduro qui avait fait
la première offre et que donald trump
répondu qu'il était toujours prêt à
rencontrer tout le monde y compris
nicholas manou l'eau mais simplement
pour lui signifier pour lui montrer la
sortie parce qu'ils ne comptent négocier
que son que son rôle que son départ
pacifique
à noter quand même que dans ses
communiqués il ne cite pas gouedo pour
lequel il n'a pas une grande estime
ce qui fait que au bout du compte la
situation entre les états unis et le
venezuela paraît finalement assez bloqué
et on ne voit pas véritablement vers
quel type déchéance on pourrait aller je
pense que en l'occurrence on n'est plus
dans de l'affichage des deux côtés
d'ailleurs que dans une réelle volonté
d'aboutir à un accord entre les deux est
ce que c'est un petit peu prématuré
audacieux de dire que donald trump est
en train de lâcher juan jose haedo
non ce n'est pas totalement prématuré
c'est fort possible en tout cas il ne
donne pas de signes de soutien
particulièrement évident est empressé
donc incontestablement la situation doit
encore mûrir comme on dit en langage
diplomatique je suppose parce que on ne
peut pas demander le départ d'un du
président en exercice
sans pour autant être en mesure
d'accepter le la venue au pouvoir de son
opposant l'état ne peut pas rester
vacants alors on en gagne deux autres
cas il semble de plus en plus en
difficulté contesté dans son propre camp
donald trump vous l'avez bien expliqué
qu'il ne soutient plus comme avant est
il clairement
en perte de vitesse et bientôt en voie
de disparition c'est toujours le
problème de la nature qui a horreur du
vide c'est à dire que si une
personnalité était susceptible de
remplacer gaido dans l'esprit des
américains oui dans ce cas là il y
aurait un plan b pour l'instant je pense
malgré tout que le plan b reste garrido
pour les américains faute de mieux et
même si il ne semble pas le trouver
particules en tout cas donald trump ne
semble pas le trouver partir vraiment à
son goût alors comment vous voyez
clairement aujourd'hui une issue de la
crise au venezuela parce que ça fait
quand même plusieurs mois que ça dure ça
fait même plusieurs années que ça dure
on a on a une situation qui est
complètement bloquée avec un pouvoir qui
est issu donc du chavisme et qui est
dans une phase révolutionnaire assumer y
compris surtout en opposition aux états
unis et l'autre côté les américains qui
cherchent à contrôler le venezuela comme
ils cherchent à contrôler tous les états
je pense en pâture et la bolivie
tous les états sud-américains qui ont eu
des velléités je dirais de 2,2
d'indépendance du moins d'autonomie via
le courant socialiste donc de toute
façon tant que maduro est au pouvoir au
venezuela
et même si trump devaient être battus au
mois de novembre la situation ne devrait
pas s'améliorer entre les deux pays
puisque je dirais que de manière
congénitales les deux les deux les deux
nos idéologies ne peuvent pas s'entendre
et justement c'était ma prochaine
question selon vous cette présidentielle
dans quelques temps dans quelques mois
en quatre mois ne peut rien changer
effectivement cette situation c'est joe
biden par exemple l'emporter on se
souvient des mots très durs que maduro
avait eu pour barack obama c'est à dire
qu'il l'avait humilié il l'avait il
avait vraiment vraiment très très mal
très mal traités hall notamment à
l'occasion des sommets des sommets année
d'aider des pays d amérique et on voit
mal joe biden qui se veut le successeur
l'héritier de barack obama s'il était
élu au mois de novembre
changer grand chose dans la vision
que les états unis peuvent avoir de
nicolás maduro et du et du venezuela de
nicolás maduro
c'est à dire que quel que soit le
changement d'exécutif aux états unis il
y a très très peu de chances que temps
que nicholas maduro sera au pouvoir au
venezuela que l'un des deux pays est
envie de faire véritablement un effort
ils sont de manière je dirais presque
enfin il de manière totalement
idéologique aux antipodes l'un de
l'autre sont ans d'opposition
l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre
particulièrement le venezuela qui fonde
une grande partie de son de sa
popularité sur l'anti-américanisme merci
olivier puis quand d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre analyse